welcome to the simply learns YouTube
channel in today's video we are going to
talk about the meta business Suite I'll
explain what it is how you use it what
the functionality is I'll show you some
screens in a in a demo that I will be
giving you we'll give you some tips and
tricks and we'll look a bit about what
the future has in stock for The Meta
business Suite as usual I am Mark kman I
am your digital navigator for this video
and if you like the video then click the
button below to subscribe to our channel
to join our fantastic learning community
on the simply learn YouTube channel but
before this let me start with sharing
with you some additional information
about simply learn if you want to
upskill yourself if you want to master
the digital marketing skills or you want
to land your dream job or grow your
career that you already have in digital
marketing then you must explore the
cohort of various digital marketing
programs that simply learn has available
for you we offer various certification
and postgraduate programs in
collaboration with some of the leading
universities and businesses like meta
and Microsoft through our courses you
will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like search engine
marketing strategies in paid campaigns
analytics Roi and evaluation and many
many others but that's not all yeah you
also get the opportunity to work on
multiple projects and learn from
industry experts working in the area on
digital marketing experts from product
companies and lecturers from top
universities and after completing these
courses liter thousands of Learners have
transitioned into a digital marketing
career and they've become very
successful so if you're passionate about
making your your career in the field of
digital marketing then make sure you
check out the simply learn website or
the link that you can see in the
comments below and that will help you to
make sure that what you're going to
learn fits your career
requirements right so let's go straight
into the meta business Suite there is
this thing called The Meta business
Suite you may have heard of it and it is
a big deal for businesses who are on
Facebook and Instagram it's not just
some regular tool it is the main hub for
all your online stuff on Facebook and on
Instagram now why does this matter well
it brings all your Facebook and
Instagram activities together in one day
dashboard yeah that means that dealing
with ads with Pages teams um analytics
and everything and posting and planning
your content all happens in one place
and the best part of this it saves you
tons of time and it keeps things simple
no more jumping between screens or
jumping between applications you can
just focus on your business as you
should be focused now the business Suite
isn't just for you it's good for your
marketing team as well so even if your
team is spread out over multiple
location it lets you work together you
can assign different responsibilities in
The Meta business weed it keeps everyone
on the same page it gives everybody
access to the same content the same ads
the same posts and the same analytics
data so you can all work towards that
same goal
but it's not about teamwork there's a
lot more in it it's like having an
advisor with you it it has tools that
will give you how engaged your audience
is with your ads how you're doing on
Facebook how you're doing on Instagram
and it helps you turns your data into
smart decisions so in simple terms The
Meta business Suite is like the behind
the scenes manager for your business in
Instagram and Facebook it is your goto
place for making things happen in a very
smart way right so what are we going to
be talking about we will be talking
about what is the meta business suite
and then I'm going to give you four
demos demo one is setting up your
business manager account demo two is
navigating the business manager
interface demo three is utilizing
Facebook insights for datadriven
decisions and demo 4 I'll share with you
some info about how to collaborate and
how to manage your team on the Business
site okay so let's get
going The Meta business Suite used to be
known as the Facebook business manager
in fact Facebook business manager is
still available um and I'll come back to
that in a minute the differences between
the meta business suite and the meta
business manager but as launched in
2014 it now is a all encompassing tool
for advertisers marketers business
owners um agencies to manage the
Facebook and Instagram business that
they are U that they are running so
there's a lot of good stuff about the
business about the meta business Suite
there's some good advantages and some
good benefits that you can get from this
it makes handling your Facebook and
Instagram account very easy there are
lots of functionality that you find in
the meta business Suite to manage your
account of Facebook and Instagram it
also allows you to manage your team
smoothly you can assign responsibilities
to team members making the communication
and getting things done on Facebook and
Instagram a lot easier there's extensive
analytics and insights that gives you
lots of information about how you're
performing on uh on Facebook and
Instagram helping you to improve your
activities there is tight security with
detailed control over who can do what on
um on Facebook and Instagram there are
tools like chat and inbox that you can
have to manage your communication with
your customers and being part of the
Meta Family it links with other met meta
platforms as well yeah like audience
management advertising messaging tools
and what have you so it is your full
package for your digital and your social
media marketing game focused on Facebook
and on Instagram good so let's look at
how to set up your business manager
account I'm going to walk you through
setting up your business account and
then we're going to show you how that
gives you access to your advertising
your pages your teams how you can post
Etc so if you go on Facebook there are
two places there is the Facebook
business manager and there is the meta
business suite and that is a bit
confusing yeah so let's talk about the
difference between the two so the
Facebook business manager and The Meta
business suite are two different
applications and they serve different
purposes yeah though the Facebook
business manager is designed for
businesses that rely on Facebook for
their marketing and advertising efforts
while the meta business Suite is
designed for businesses that want to
manage their total online presence yeah
the meta business manager is free and it
helps you manage your Facebook page the
advertising and all your assets in one
place once you have a Facebook page bu
business page it is essential to have
met a business B manager as further
development of your Facebook and your
Instagram so the business manager allows
you to create and track your ad
campaigns that you are managing it helps
you access and control billing settings
and create custom audiences for your ads
and you have the the option to allocate
specific tasks across your team but it's
very much focused on um on Facebook and
the core functionality of managing your
Facebook page but the business um also
by the way the business manager gives
you the ability to manage your meta
pixels or your Facebook pixels that you
can use for retargeting so everything
you want to do with your Facebook page
you can do within the Facebook business
manager but Facebook learned or meta
learned that people wanted more people
wanted to manage their Instagram do
their posting do their content calendar
so they needed more functionality and
that's where Facebook came out with the
meta business Suite that is a
centralized area to manage your Facebook
your Instagram you're messaging in one
place so you can save time to manage
your business and to manage your
connections and develop relationships
with more people so cross functionality
is one of the business Suite most
appealing features so the ability to F
all your social activities at a glance
in One dashboard manage multiple
Facebook inboxes and making your
Community Management very simple to do
you can also create and schedule posts
and stories on both Facebook and
Instagram through the meta business uh
the business suite and it's also a great
tool for managing and tracking your page
insights and managing tracking trends
that can help you better understand your
audiences
so in summary meta business Suite is an
application that should be used if you
are looking for an easier way to post
engage with your communities across
Facebook and your Instagram business
accounts where the meta business manager
is a site to be used if you're looking
to run ad campaigns with a team in
control your business account settings
and manage your Facebook page so here
are the two introduction screens here's
the screen for the business manager that
you will see but what we're going to
focus on today is the meta business
Suite so if I click here it takes me to
the welcome screen of the meta business
Suite it shows you the get started gives
you lots of functionality it talks about
leads you to the advertising lots of
places where you can learn where you can
get support yep and then here you find
more information about The Meta business
Suite with case studies how to get
started tips and what have you and
everywhere you see that button get
started yeah so definitely before you
start with using the meta business Suite
go through this website to familiarize
yourself with all the ins and outs of
the Facebook or The Meta business suite
and when you're ready to start using the
meta business Suite you just click on
the start start now button and that will
take you to the dashboard of the meta
business suite and this is your onetop
shop as it were that gives you access to
all the functionality within the meta
business Suite so it's based on a page
yeah so here you have a page that I own
which a riat for Russia is a place in in
Marakesh that I have a website for and a
Facebook page and an Instagram page
and um here you see the management place
for the riat for Russia on Facebook and
on Instagram so here you see the menu of
functionality so you see notifications
planner content insights the inbox
monetization advertising and a lot more
tools that you have access to you have
also got access to the settings here and
then here you have your sort of your
to-do list
manage your marketing content how you
can gives you tips on how to explore
more ways to grow your audience and um
it's sort of the new center as well of
new elements that and new items and new
functionality that you can find in the
business uh The Meta business
Suite okay so that is the screen that
you will get when you already have a
account if you don't have an account
yeah you go here on RI in the screen
here what you will get yeah instead of
seeing this screen you will actually see
this screen create a business account
create a meta business account and
there's a few things that you need to do
here first of all you need to create
your
account second you provide your business
details and third you complete the
verification and once you've created or
completed the verification you're going
to add your accounts like your pages and
your advertising accounts and you're
going to invite team members and to
close this you're going to configure
business settings and start verifying
other features like your website for
instance and then you are ready to start
using your Facebook or your meta
business Suite so quickly let's go
through that yeah so you're putting in
your name so that could be uh Mark
riat yeah you put in your contact info
that would be Mark campman and then very
important you're going to put in your
email and this email email must be
related to your uh Facebook page of
course yeah so that is where they will
Facebook or meta will connect your email
with your Facebook page and you will
also need the Facebook or the email
addresses from other people that you
want to assign and with for a
functionality on your um on your meta
business Suite okay so that is how you
create your business account so then
you're going to click let me just put in
here my email you click create yeah
you're then coming to the next screen
where you're going to start filling in
more business information and where
you're going to provide more business
details yep so here you see Mark Riad
then you can connect different pages to
it you can select relevant business
assets like claim Facebook pages and
accounts that are related to this
business or you can edit this section
later as well so that's how you can
claim and link to your business account
so let's say we're going to add another
Facebook page to this I'm going to skip
this for now I can do this later you're
then going to add other business people
to your business account if you want
to yep and we'll come back to that later
when we going to specif ify what type of
people you're going to add to your
account and what functionality you're
giving them I'm going to skip this yep
and then you're going to review and
confirm okay and once you've completed
this you're happy with this you confirm
and then Facebook will verify this and
you will basically get an email it will
confirm your but let's see what happens
if I press yeah so here you see how
Facebook has uh set it up yeah so now
it's Mark's re business account here is
the name the account ID and I can now
add my business assets I can invite
people and I create an account I can set
a billing and payment for this account I
can set up the language settings I can
set add Partnerships and I can add my
business Assets in the meantime I will
have received an email from um from
Facebook where I need to verify this
this account so quite a comprehensive
setup but once you've done that you are
basically ready to add your assets and
ready to run your Facebook um your
Facebook pages or manage your Facebook
and Instagram page through the meta
business Suite so let's go back to the
riat for Russia meta business suite and
let's go to the second demo which is to
navigate the business manager or the
business Suite
interface this part of the demo is
crucial yeah understanding the layout
the tools and TS is like unlocking the
secrets for smoothly cruising through
the meta business Suite you want to know
where things are and how to use them to
make the most of this tool so let's
start with exploring the dashboard and
think of this of your mission control
yeah the place where you get the big
picture of what's happening with your
Facebook and your Instagram pages and
then we'll peek into an ad account this
is where the magic happens with your ads
and how to get familiar with using the
ads because that is critical in growing
your your Facebook and your Instagram
presence and of course we'll look at the
pages as well where do you manage your
pages where because they are the
storefronts of your Facebook and your
Instagram and managing them well is
essential to keeping your online
presence on point now there are other
topics as well like L using at how do
you post content how do you plan your
content but we'll look at that at at
later demos so let's start with the
dashboard overall here on the left you
have your menu if you click here on all
tools you get an extensive menu with all
the
functionality and then here in the
center you have your dashboard dashboard
with the look and feel of your page or
your
Instagram yep and it will also give you
the to-do list it gives you draft posts
that are in the process and it gives you
details of your marketing content the
planner your post reels and your stories
and it gives you tips on how to grow
your presence on um on Facebook and on
Instagram this is the home screen here
you have
notifications are important because this
is where you get messages from things
happening in your Facebook and your
Instagram World here is your planner is
a really cool tool where you can plan
your
content okay here you have your content
here you have your
insights here you have back to the
menu yeah let's go back to the inbox
here is your email inbox here is info
about monetizing your Facebook Instagram
um content through uh through
advertising and what else have we got
we're talking about advertising and here
are all your tools as we saw that the
tools are
about getting active in your Facebook
and your Instagram so there's a section
about creating posts and stories and ads
and go live yeah there is section about
engaging with your audience a section
about
advertising a very important part of
your advertising are the
audiences there is about your Commerce
Facebook Commerce which is selling
products and services here is a section
about managing all the details like your
billing safety business apps
collaboration file manager page settings
and what have you and here is analyze
and reports which are ads reporting and
insights they're the most important ones
yep so that is in a nutshell and then
here you have search there's help and
here you have settings which is very
important tool as well because that's
where you can specify the settings in
using your meta business
with right so this is what the dashboard
is all about this is all about making
your life easier and your business
management game Stronger Yeah so let's
dig in there and let's go into a bit
more details there's dedicated areas for
advertising and for your pages okay so
if I click here on the all tools I show
that there is dedicated areas for
advertising on an ad level or even on an
ad manager level yeah and it's very
important that you understand how you
work with this so click on these buttons
explore them it's where the advertising
magic happens so it gives you kind of
the backp pass entrance to all your ads
when you want to check on your ads want
to tweak them or see how they're
performing this is the place where you
want to go so it is a must to understand
how to use these ads yeah and and how to
use the ads manager we'll go later this
is a series of three videos in the third
video we're going to get more details on
accessing the ads manager and the ads
yeah there's also the section on the
pages these are like the shop window of
Facebook and Instagram presence manage
them well yeah is very important if you
go to the page
settings yeah so it allows you to set
the pages the the details of your pages
it sets the Privacy for your pages it
sets the locations you can link accounts
videos branded content lots of elements
that you can set here for your pages so
go through that make sure that you
understand how to manage this okay so
it's opened a new window so I can just
close that window to go back to my
business manager to my business Suite I
have to say Okay so most important thing
here this dashboard gives you access to
all the functionality of your meta
business suite and a very important
button to close this section with is on
the settings and in the settings you can
set set up your language billing ad
account settings and you may have seen
this earlier when we've set up the um
the account in the business manager yeah
so if you want to revisit that if you
want to make changes then you can do
that here in the settings
area now that you understand the
dashboard let's dig a bit deeper into a
very important section in The Meta
business Suites which which are your
meta insights that is not just another
tool it is the data Hub of your Facebook
and Instagram presence where you can get
information about your audience about
how your pages are doing and whether
your advertising is achieving its
objectives it gives you kind of a cheat
cheet for making decisions you want to
know about who your audience is you want
to know where they are insights gives
you that data you're in curious about
your face Facebook page performance
check it out on the inside in on the
inside you want to know how your ads are
performing meta insights will give you
the detail so this is basically where
you go to become a strategic
thinker armed with real time information
about your Facebook and your Instagram
presence so let's have a look at this
let's go to the
insights yes so so heading over to the
meta page so let's go to the old
tools yep and there's two different ways
of going there you can access that
through your page or you can access it
here through your
insights and this is where you're going
to get a gold mine of
information about your presence on
Facebook yes so and it sorts it neatly
into sections like page views followers
engagement and um your content you want
to know how many views you got here you
can see how many you got you want to
know how your ads are running here you
can see how they are doing you want to
know your audience you want to know more
about your followers about your
Instagram followers here is where you
can find all that information and all
that knowledge now these aren't not just
numbers on the screen these numbers they
tell you what is happening and they can
help you refining your Facebook strategy
it helps you to tweak your Instagram and
your Facebook strategy and it can helps
you in checking how your audience is
responding yeah it is really good
information so take for instance
information about your audience yeah it
gives you the followers it gives you on
Facebook and Instagram you it also gives
you detail about age and gender of your
followers it gives them where are they
coming
from yeah the top cities or the top
countries so you can Benchmark this data
with
competitors yeah you can also look at
your content so the content is a very
important one this is probably in my
opinion one of the most important TAPS
in the uh meta insights section so this
dissects your posts and it shows you how
each of your post is
doing when it comes to number of people
reached number of people that have seen
the post number of people that have seen
the video you can watch uh split it by
post and by stories you can split it by
let's just do photo posts no photo post
mostly we we're video posts yep and you
can specify the columns here as well so
I want to see the type of
post yeah so I can then apply and it
gives you lots of information here you
see on the videos how many minutes
people viewed the post how many
Impressions that you got the reach of
the post post and the most important one
is the engagement on the post and that
is this button is the reactions likes
comments and share this is a critical
column in your Facebook in uh your
Facebook insights yeah if I order this
from top
down yeah so here then I see those posts
with the highest engagement over the
last 28 days and this is where you can
learn what posts work and what posts do
not work and that is golden information
because if you know this post works then
why not make more of those posts so
people can um so you can get in similar
engagement level and overall it can help
you in driving your engagement
levels so very useful reports you can
see what posts are stealing the shows
what posts need a bit of
tweaking and it can help you in making
sure that you hit the right content with
the right the right people with the
right content so think about this tab
the content tab as checking what posts
work and what those post don't work and
you can use that to optimize your posts
for um
future so there's a lot more in here you
can get audience information here as
well and we'll talk about that in a um
in a later demo on how to develop
audiences in your Facebook your your
meta
insights right let's move on let's go to
the fourth and final demo of this video
which is about collaboration and Team
Management let's go back to the meta
business week
in this demo we'll dive into the world
of collaboration and Team Management
within your meta business Suite so metab
business Suite is not just an act for
you it's not a solo act it is about
getting your whole marketing team on
Facebook on the meta business Suite yep
and that can help you in kind of
supercharging your uh your management of
your Facebook and your Instagram so
let's break down how you can add team
members because teamwork is like the
secret source that can really make your
better meta business Suite come to life
so it is very useful to get your team
online so it helps you keep people in
the loop you can assign specific
roles yeah so everybody knows what
they're doing what they're supposed to
be doing when they get on the on the
meta business suite and very important
even if your page is across or if your
team is across multiple locations you
can still work as a team in managing
your um your Facebook and your Instagram
so let's go down to the basics the first
of this is building your team so what
you're going to do you're going to move
to the business settings and here you
see
people yeah already you here see an
overview of the people that
are available on this business
account that can use and there's
currently one that is me and I've done
another one which is me on another email
and the invite has been sent but I
haven't accepted it but let's go and
click an invite let's first look here on
the people button that is basically that
leads you to this scream if I click here
on invite people
you can then go through a number of
steps yeah so in this section you can
select
people once you've select those people
you can assign their access you can
assign business assets to those people
you can review the invitation and then
you can send it out so let's go through
this process so we're going to enter the
email again we're going to do just
myself
[Music]
uh yep and I can get temporary access or
for the advanced option I can remove but
I'm just doing it yeah so this is
actually quite useful temporary access
for instance if you want like an agency
you want them to have a quick look at
your Facebook insights for instance you
can just give them temporary access for
the day and then you want to switch it
off
yeah on uh that particular uh that
particular time frame we're not going to
do that I'm just going to click
next and then here you can specify the
access that you want to give to this
person yes so you can give the person
partial access or you can give the
person full control so partial access is
the K they can only work on the tasks
and the business assets assigned to them
basic access yeah which was formerly the
employee role is the default access that
everyone gets when they are added okay
so that is what you can set you can
integrate with um with apps and
different in Integrations like the
Facebook pixel that people can view them
and manage them I'm not going to do this
in this case or you can give somebody
full control which is like an admin role
yeah so that would be the bu business
admin role and they can manage
everything including settings people
tools business asset they can delete a
business account yeah so does not
include the advanced options so you need
to be careful with this but once you
give somebody full
control yep then um they are basically
an admin for that so click shared then
there you can also look at the financial
information like transactions invoices
accounts
and payment method so that could be for
your finance manager for instance so I
am just going to be full
control yeah so I'm happy with that no
no let's not do this I am actually none
I'm just going to be a basic control and
I click next I can then assign business
assets so there is the Facebook page
there is the ad account I can assign
products I can assign the Instagram
account the Commerce account I can
assign pixels data sets so lots of stuff
that I can assign here okay so the
Facebook page and the Instagram account
that's what I want this person to be
assigned I can then review business
assets not assigned sign business assets
I then here need probably to specify can
manage the content yeah so Insight add
oh select a business asset so the r for
Russia page yep I can then assign
content Community activity ads insights
and leads okay that's all I want to get
and then I'll click next and then I'm
going to send an
invitation to Mark markm man.com and as
soon as I accept the
invitation I will then show up on this
list as we saw here yeah and accepted
and I am then part of the team that
manages the um that manage the Facebook
or The Meta business suite for this
particular page right so that's a wrap
an introduction to The Meta business
Suite let me summarize yeah the meta
business Suite is a OneStop shop for
managing your business presence on
Facebook and on
Instagram it was formerly known as the
Facebook business manager Facebook
business manager is still available no
new developments but is great if you
just manage a Facebook page and want to
manage your advertising if you want to
do more if you want to manage everything
on your Facebook and Instagram accounts
from your page your advertising your
messaging your content you name it then
the meta business place is there to
streamline your communication and
getting valuable insights through the
meta insights and that empowers your
business to fully utilize all the
functionalities that Facebook and
Instagram have to offer you and it
enables you to make informed decisions
on real data on how to optimize your
Facebook and Instagram to be successful
and if if you want to know more about
this there will be two more videos to
come on The Meta business Suite in this
series of three
videos in the second video we will be
talking about posting and planning your
content on meta business suite and in
the third video we're going to be
looking at advertising more details
about insights and we're going to be
looking at making money Facebook and
Instagram by managing your Commerce
through uh The Meta business Suite so
check out the new videos that are coming
in the next few weeks or check out other
simply link courses that you may be
interested in and again if you like this
video then please click the like button
or the share button and con uh click the
button to join our YouTube community on
um to learn more about digital marketing
and the button to subscribe is as usual
below and that is all that I have for
today I will be seeing you in the next
video where we're going to be talking
about the posting and planning and
content of your meta business Suite take
care staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to no
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here